a decade ago this wheelchair was the
height of Technology in the disability
sector for max Bert it was a
life-changing innovation but now he's
developing his own applying even more
modern technology to services Bert's
innovation is a website that guides
people with disabilities to places they
can access this cafe has stairs leading
down from its front door useless for
people in wheelchairs the app shows an
unsigned alternative entrance through an
office block being a supervisor style
website you can add information yourself
so for example you you could add your
local cafe to our website in time Bert
hopes mapping apps will integrate his
information to show wheelchair friendly
routes innovation is taking off in
Australia because of a new
taxpayer-funded 22 billion Australian
dollar or 15 billion u.s. dollar a year
National Disability Insurance Scheme
supported by both the country's main
political parties grants are given
directly to people with disability to
spend on the services they need we're
seeing investors are really taking this
this space seriously with the advent of
the National Disability Insurance Scheme
seeing that government is increasing
their spending from around about six
billion dollars a year to 22 billion
dollars a year it's a it's a market that
is really unparalleled in lots of ways
many startups like those represented at
this networking event have flourished
technology is at the heart of most Pat
and Glenn Metz with the help of one of
them higher up is an online platform
that helps people find hire and manage
their own support workers traditionally
agencies would find workers people with
disabilities would have little choice
over who they got and that person would
change frequently in the past I had no
choice in who supported me
it was very disempowering now I have
full choice in control not only with
I have supporting me but when they come
in what we do the platform means people
with disability can choose their own
support workers based on availability
and mutual interests that leads to
consistency and often to friendship
without technology you wouldn't be able
to have this immediate connection with
people so if with Glenn within 30
minutes God sent a message send a
message back and arrange to meet up the
next day I'd started working with him
technology in the disability sector is
often thought of only in the physical
realm increasingly its services online
that are powering the innovation Andrew
Thomas al-jazeera